game saves are important but how far
would you go to ensure yours remains
intact I'm Kate and this is your
gamespot news update one Japanese gamer
left his Super Famicom known as the
snares in the US powered on for 20 years
to make sure he didn't lose his save for
Omaha Rock awaaz a a platforming game
released back in 1994 the ultra
dedicated fan tweeted about the game
safe scenario back in September and the
story is picking up traction again this
week the fan at Omaha Rock awaaz a on
Twitter tweeted a picture of the classic
game console running the game as well as
his game save data the fan was worried
that he might lose his save data because
the cartridge used static Ram with
lithium-ion batteries as long as the
battery stayed charged the safe data
would remain intact if you turn the
console off or removed the cartridge it
would eventually lose its charge and the
game save would be gone the fan says his
console has been powered on and running
Omaha Rocca was a for over a hundred and
eighty thousand hours as of sep tember
2015 he switched off the console just
one time when he moved but claims he was
able to power it back up before the
cartridge lost its battery what's the
oldest game save you have let us know in
the comments below or come find me on
Twitter I'm at how not to draw remember
to keep it gamespot com for all your
gaming news thanks for watching and
Happy New Year